[Musique]
bonjour à tous si je m'appelle henry
henry cordeau 1
je suis né sourd je peux parler mais pas
assez bien pour que vous puissiez
comprendre c'est pour ça que je fais
intervenir une interprète qui peut vous
faire comprendre ce que je dis en langue
des signes
saint-exupéry aurait tout à fait pu être
sourd parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
énormément de bruit dans les avions
et il n'y avait pas de radio il ya
également un autre pilote qui s'appelle
lindbergh qui a qu'à qui a traversé
l'océan atlantique de new york jusqu'à
paris pendant 33 eur et cela sans radio
et c'était en 1927 10% de la population
française ont des problèmes d'audition
alors vous allez me dire qu'est ce que
ça fait si on n'entend pas est ce que
vraiment on peut piloter
est-ce que vous par exemple vous seriez
monté avec sa tombe du père et s'il
avait été sourd je vais avoir 58 ans
après demain
j'ai passé les deux tiers de ma vie à
voler souvent les personnes m'ont dit
qu'ils n'en est pas capable
c'est pas possible que tu pilotes et
pourtant j'ai été le premier élève de
l'école nationale de l'aviation civile
de toulouse en 1982 et à ce moment là
j'étais au courant qu'en amérique
de nombreux pilotes sourds exister en
france c'était très très compliqué pour
obtenir une licence
peu importe je suis parti en amérique et
j'ai obtenu ma licence en cinq semaines
je suis devenu pilote d'avion
c'était en 1990 suite à ça j'ai refait
le même coup de poker en angleterre en
j'ai également vécu une superbe aventure
en volant en australie alors c'est vrai
qu'il est très difficile difficile
d'obtenir une dérogation médical pour
devenir pilote privé
dès qu'on a un handicap auditif les
médecins en général refuse de nous
donner cet axe-là alors vous allez me
dire mais comment est-ce possible
enfin est ce que est ce que vous n'êtes
pas un peu fou de volée alors que vous
êtes sourd souvent les personnes se
disant un pilote source est pas possible
parce qu' il ne peut pas utiliser la
radio mais la radio c'est pas obligé
bien sûr c'est obligé si on veut être
pilote de ligne pilote de transport
pilote dans l'armée etc
mais en france il ya environ deux tiers
des aérodromes qui sont dépourvus de
tour de contrôle
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas la radio
l'une des normes principal de l'aviation
c'est d'être vu un pilote se doit devoir
est d'éviter pour la sécurité de tous
les pilotes
il faut être vu et être vu et voir par
exemple être vu et voir quand on
atterrit quand on décolle et pour éviter
toute collision et ce à un sourd on est
tout à fait capable
il y a des moyens qui sont mises en
oeuvre par exemple les gps les
transpondeurs qui permettent une
communication sans radio mais il ya
également des moyens de communication
visuelle et via des flashs
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière c'est
via la course devient la tour de
contrôle qui envoie ses flashs la aux
avions qui sont dans l'espace aérien est
par exemple c'est très utilisé pour des
exercices de panne radio mercredi
dernier j'étais près de paris j'ai
effectué un vol et j'ai utilisé ce
système là son problème
le monde de l'aviation
ça me fait penser il ya dans les années
50 pour les personnes sourdes qui
souhaitait conduire à cette époque là
les personnes disaient ah nan nan
personnes sourdes dont elle peut pas
conduire c'est interdit c'est pas
possible
regardez maintenant les personnes
sourdes conduisent c'est un fait tout à
fait banal alors j'espère qu'il aura la
même évolution pour les avions mais
c'est vrai que c'est très très difficile
de convaincre le conseil médical qui
malheureusement ne donne qu au compte
gouttes les autorisations pour que les
personnes sourdes puisse voler ses
réticences qu'on le conseil médical aux
états unis elle n'existe pas aux états
unis il ya plus de 250 sourds qui ont la
licence de pilote
ils ont cette licence de ppl d'avions
privés et ce avant il va y en avoir de
plus en plus il y à des américains il y
à un australien un non droit un français
que je connais également dans d'autres
pays par exemple en australie
il y environ une dizaine de pilotes
sourds en angleterre il y en a une
quinzaine il y en aura bientôt brésil et
bien sûr j'espère qu'il y en aura
plusieurs en france
alors il y à des solutions innovantes
je participe d'ailleurs un nouveau
projet qui s'appelle fans ce forum comme
vous pouvez le voir ce projet permet de
donner des solutions aux communications
par radio
c'est un projet qui permet de développer
un nouvel équipement pour les avis pour
les avions permettant la communication
bidirectionnelle entre la tour de
contrôle et les avions c'est un système
qui fonctionne au moyen de signaux
textuelle et d'un indicateur lumineux
c'est un moyen qui est fait à partir de
normes existantes qui sont développés et
déjà réalisés depuis les années 80 pour
un système qui s'appelle cp dlc qui est
utilisé d'ailleurs dans les avions de
ligne c'est en évolution et ça va être
adapté aux plus petits avions alors
évidemment les personnes sourdes vont
bénéficier mais en fait tous les pilotes
pour en bénéficier pour atterrir pour
décoller pour permettre un contrôle plus
précis
alors évidemment il faut accélérer le
développement alors comme je vous le
disais les sourds en bénéficieront mais
également les entendons c'est un nouvel
outil de communication plus sûr et plus
fiable pour tous les avions et pour tout
l'espace aérien qui devient
malheureusement de plus en plus saturé
c'est vraiment une solution intéressante
pour également les pilotes qui ont des
problèmes d'élocution
il y a également lu lm c'est vrai que ça
donne une véritable liberté parce qu'il
ya beaucoup moins de contraintes et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya environ une
quarantaine de sourds qui utilise lui
elle aime mes combats et ma persévérance
m'ont permis d'obtenir enfin ma licence
en 2007 en france
enfin j'ai maintenant plus de deux mille
trois cents heures de vol en avion et en
ulm alors volé c'est incroyable c'est un
sentiment de liberté
alors ça enlève toutes les inquiétudes
du quotidien des problèmes sociale ou du
travail personnel j'aime énormément
c'est c'est ma passion et c'est pour ça
qu'avec les personnes qui m'encourage
qui me soutiennent je discute énormément
avec eux c'est un vrai partage en
parlant de partage je suis instructeur
également du lm pour des élèves sourds
et malentendants à l'aérodrome de
coulommiers à côté de paris
en france la france c'est un beau pays
et je pense que la france peut nous
aider à réaliser nos rêves
la frustration c'est un sentiment qui
n'est pas agréable
et pourtant beaucoup de sourds et de
malentendants le ressentent
mais c'est aussi une force ça nous
permet de repousser les limites les
limites que nous donne la législation
ces normes qui ne devrait pas être alors
il faut se battre pour dépasser les
épreuves bon en bon gascon que je suis
je dis souvent un pour tous et tous pour
un et la vie m'a aussi appris
aide toi et le ciel t'aidera
mais s'il y a un message que je veux
vous transmettre à vous tous aujourd'hui
cela vient d'un ami à moi qui est
également pilote gérard fait l'air qui
est ici présents qui dit si tu peux
vas-y merci d'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]